hey gq i'm dr jordan newen i'm a
biomedical engineer inventor and
futurist and this is part two of the
breakdown
[Music]
in this episode we'll be breaking down
biomedical tech
hi robot
[Music]
so this motor prosthetic design looks
quite advanced it obviously looks like
an arm from the outside
and you see him having some form of
super strength as well when he punches
straight into the ground there we're
getting to the point in time where
prosthetics and motor prosthetics and
even exoskeletons can be built in a way
that are actually becoming more and more
functional and useful and we're going to
see these advancements continue to occur
how dell's
prosthetic arm would likely work
is through a neural system where the
electrical signals that his brain is
trying to send out from the motor cortex
is sending out those signals and he's in
control of his arm whilst also getting
feedback this is already in some ways
possible the more rudimentary versions
utilize what's called emg
electromyography which can pick up on
the electrical signals that your brain
is sending to the muscles so we can pick
up on those with electrodes as well we
can put them anywhere on the body to
pick up the electrical signals and get
an idea of what's going on then on top
of that we've got eog
electro-oculography which is the
electrical signals of the eyes whenever
we move our eyes our brain sends
electrical signals to the little muscles
that push and pull them that's something
i utilized in my documentary becoming
superhuman my young friend riley could
only move his eyes born with high-level
cerebral palsy his dream was to drive a
car so we picked up on the electrical
signals of his eyes to allow him to gain
control over a vehicle literally with
the electrical activity of his eyes what
dell has here is not one of those
simpler versions of the technology
utilizing emg to control the motor
prosthetic instead it's obviously built
into his arm built into the system so he
would have a technology that's picking
up on the neural activity from inside uh
the brain and directly controlling the
arm with the motor prosthetic like dolls
here you've got control of the fingers
the hand the arms probably a strong type
of
material like titanium so you could
actually get what is effectively super
strength
these are the sort of things that can be
built already into exoskeletons where
you wear
a suit on the outside of your body and
these have been utilized to allow people
to lift weights that are already too
heavy for them these types of
technologies can be lightweight can be
strong and can provide superhuman
strength there've been people who have
had
motor prosthetics built for them that do
have neural interfaces so that they are
controlling it effectively with their
mind so this is already possible it's
just going to keep advancing to get to
this point that's seamless and looks
like it's part of the body the matrix
[Music]
this
is the world that you know
the world as it was at the end of the
20th century
it exists now only as part of a neural
interactive simulation
that we call the matrix
you've been living in a dream world neo
this whole backstory of the matrix the
idea of artificial intelligence becoming
on par with humans to the point where ai
in robots
started getting to
its own conscious level and deciding to
have an uprising against the humans the
human body generates more bioelectricity
than a 120 volt battery and over 25 000
btus of body heat
the human body does generate electricity
or doesn't does generate energy and so
the robots chose to turn humans into a
power source into a battery and to do
that they put us into these pods and
then they had to try and keep the mind
active and alive they built a virtual
world which is the world that we know
today and injected it into our brain
there's a potential that we are living
in a simulation you can't prove that
we're not if we project a few decades
into the future we could create a
virtual world that's
so
similar to the real world that we have
today
if it could also be combined with brain
computer interface technology where we
can inject that virtual world into the
brain what's possible that this has
already happened
and we are living in a simulation the
matrix is a computer-generated dream
world
built to keep us under control
in order to change a human being
into this
so this is a it's a freaky look at the
this dystopic future where humans have
become batteries for the machines we're
living out our lives trapped in a
virtual world that we don't even realize
we're in so how can you possibly escape
this scene in the movie leads on to
morpheus describing to neo what is
reality and our reality our individual
reality is a constant
construction based on the electrical
signals the electrochemical signals all
our different sensors sent to the brain
the brain is
it's there locked in a dark jar inside
the skull and it's being sent these
electrical
signals and uses that to construct our
version of reality sight smell touch
taste
and hearing in the matrix we go a step
further to sensory injection where they
plug this this strange
syringe like plug into the back of the
head and then it injects the whole
virtual world all the sensory
information everything directly into the
brain and that's how neo and uh and more
fears go straight into the virtual world
and are just there existing inside this
virtual space
pacific rim
[Music]
neural handshake strong and holding
right hemispheres calibrating
left hemisphere calibrating
[Music]
i'll pause it there i i do like the
pacific rim movies i mean you've got
giant robots fighting giant aliens
what's not to like so in pacific rim
you've got two pilots in unison
controlling this large robot the jager a
neural interface that's picking up on
the electrical signals of the brain and
connecting the two pilots and then
connecting them with the uh with the
actual robot that they're controlling
the jaeger they've also got as you could
see
around their feet they've got
haptic feedback and they've got these
systems where they're actually
mechanically pushing so the movements
that they're making are then being
translated into uh the robot and it's
also getting feedback where they can
feel the feedback in the uh
the forces that the robot is actually
coming across these are already used in
real-world systems including in surgery
so they can do this thing called gearing
as well which is often used in in
surgery robots where the surgeon will be
able to control these instruments and
through their own movements can be
turned into a robotic movement at a much
finer and precise level a bigger
movement
of the arms will translate into a tiny
movement in the uh in the actual
surgical equipment you could also have
the
surgeon on the other side of the world
controlling this robot in another
location there's so many different
ways and methods that you can go about
it in this one they seem to have uh
something built into their helmets that
allows them to have this this kind of
neural connections a couple of
electrodes on the back of the head can
pick up the tiny little electrical
signals from outside the skull from the
outside of the skull it's quite
difficult to pick up on the accurate
detail and this is where
intelligent systems like artificial
intelligence can help decode those
signals but being able to get further
into the action by implanting
electrodes on the say the motor cortex
of the brain this is where you can get a
brain computer interface that has a much
greater level of control the fifth
element
[Music]
this was a futuristic take on how to
fabricate a human body from the dna but
what was interesting about this was it
was actually a really good take on
actually how a 3d printer tends to
operate where layer by layer you have a
printer with an extruder head being able
to melt something like plastic polymer
and print small layer by small layer
creating any three-dimensional object 3d
printing went from
printing in in plastics
to other areas as well i've seen it
scaled up to the point where it can
print in concrete and then more recently
it's moved into the space of what's
called 3d bio printing so this is where
the ink is used the bio ink is actually
built sometimes from
a human body from human cells that can
then print something like bone tissue
i've seen work done on
on liver cells being printed valves for
the heart even
movements towards trying to test out an
entire artificial 3d printed heart i've
watched a 3d printer printing a type of
skin
straight onto a person's arm straight
onto a wound these experiments are
happening around the world the 3d
printing of bone would actually be layer
by layer much finer layers than this i
love the the scene where the the muscles
are being sort of dragged out and put
across the body i thought that was very
creative what you don't see in this they
skipped over it quite conveniently is
how the brain was created i would have
skipped over that into making this film
as well because to do something like 3d
print the brain is not going to happen
anytime soon
passengers
[Music]
multiple procedures are not recommended
do it now
executing
[Music]
pretty cool thing pretty cool idea
having having this this medical pod that
can do all of these different functions
it's a sci-fi possibility when she goes
through and she presses everything i
mean she kind of pressed on everything
to do with resuscitation there was
oxygenation there was defibrillation
these things happen when you're trying
to resuscitate a person and the part
that comes last is where uh the electric
shock is is given to the body do you
often see them in movies where you know
you've got your your doctor going
charging the device and saying clear
they say clear because otherwise it will
actually electrocute someone else if
they're touching the person who's being
defibrillated what you're trying to do
is to get the heart not only beating
properly again but it's got to beat back
in rhythm having a medical pod like this
would be something that i think many
people would want to see medical
equipment and biomedical equipment has
moved into this space where autonomously
they're operating and doing so many more
features than ever before and there's
more devices being created cinematically
this this pot is beautiful and it would
be great to see this type of medical
device created where it has all these
different functions all built into it
what i do like about passengers is not
just how this pod looks it's the whole
thing i love so much about the designs
of what has gone into the spaceship it
moves and rotates around its axis to
create an artificial gravity like a
centrifuge and that's what creates that
sort of artificial gravity
the spacecraft is more or less robotic
and able to
automatically take itself through to the
location run different types of
diagnostics on itself
and any failures that are happening more
broadly looking at how a spacecraft
would travel and find its way through
space
it's actually a very difficult thing to
localize or locate yourself if you move
a sufficient distance away from the
earth constellations will change and
then they'll disappear we won't be able
to see that perspective on the universe
anymore and this has actually come up in
many designs for the likes of space
travel if we send a probe outside of our
own solar system how is it going to ever
find its way to where it's trying to get
to one of the
potential solutions is looking at
pulsars so sometimes when stars explodes
these stars can often be around four to
eight times the size of our own sun when
these stars explode they leave this very
solid
core and it's it's a very strong
dense core and the core can be about the
size of a city they beam out
electromagnetic radiation and they spin
because they're spinning and they're
sending out radiation beams if those
radiation beams flash across the earth
they become like lighthouses so if we
know where those pulsars are across the
galaxy it can be used to do things like
localize a spacecraft that's even gone
outside of our own solar system this can
become a wayfinding system for a
galactic gps
ready player one
you don't need a destination when you're
running on an omnidirectional treadmill
with quadrophonic pressure sensitive
underlay
james halliday saw the future
and then he built it
he gave us a place to go
a place called
the oasis in this scene wade is in the
back of a van he's got this full virtual
reality set up to allow him to go into
the oasis in the late 80s early 90s we
had a boom in virtual reality technology
and my father when i was young he put a
big headset on me it gave me an
incredible headache but i could see it
was the future the technology died out
while everyone focused on the rise of
the internet but it came back around
2012 uh with palma lucky in the oculus
rift what wade is running on is called
the infinidek it's actually a real
omnidirectional treadmill but because
when you go into the virtual world you
can't see really anything around you in
the real world
he's also being held up and this is uh
is actually built into these
omnidirectional treadmills to hold the
person upright so they don't fall over
it's a fusion of many different types of
sensory stimulation technologies to
immerse the person into feeling and
believing that they are in the virtual
world and this is the idea of virtual
reality anything becomes possible you go
into the virtual world and you can
create anything that your imagination
can come up with
[Music]
this is now moving into this space which
ready player one brings up is the idea
of the metaverse the metaverse is not
any one location any one application
what it is is it's really starting to
bring together different virtual worlds
and a lot of them can be linked by the
ability to create the likes of avatars
and move those between different virtual
spaces you know jobs are going to go to
the metaverse in the near future we're
going to see many different types of
work as well as gaming as well as
entertainment and all these other
applications as well what we're really
seeing is
virtual worlds and reality slowly
intertwining so it's going to come down
to us individually as to how we decide
to spend our time because balance is
always going to be key you've got to
find balance in our lives
jurassic park
this fossilized tree sap which we call
amber waited for millions of years with
the mosquito inside
until jurassic park scientists came
along
using sophisticated techniques they
extract the preserved blood from the
mosquito and
bingo
dino dna and bingo dino dna
where there's a problem with this
particular clip is we don't have this
level of dna
of dinosaurs so unfortunately the whole
idea of having a jurassic park is is
still pretty far-fetched one
unfortunately over 65 million years
those
bits of dna have degraded over time just
imagine you've got a a full jigsaw
puzzle of
tyrannosaurus rex and that's a thousand
piece jigsaw puzzle if you've been left
over time
losing pieces and only been left with 10
pieces out of this thousand that's kind
of representative of what we have of
dino dna
there have been different efforts and
one in particular has come up a lot more
recently where some harvard geneticists
were granted 15 million dollars to bring
back the woolly mammoth from the dna
information that they do have they've
also got the closest living relative of
the woolly mammoth which is the asian
elephant the idea that they're
approaching it with is to in iterative
steps uh bring about a woolly mammoth
elephant hybrid and to be able to edit
the gene sequences in any way
this is a newer technology as well it's
called crispr cast nine crispr is a um
they're basically sets of of gene
sequences and what it really is is
molecular scissors so how crispr cast 9
would be utilized in in this particular
space is by
sequencing the genome of
the asian elephant and then also getting
the the dna sequences that they do have
of the woolly mammoth in doing things
like identifying the features that they
need to pull out of the gene sequences
of the asian elephant and putting in the
pieces of the woolly mammoth this is
where crispy cast 9 gene editing is
starting to be used in these different
types of applications we've even seen
some experiments that have been starting
up on human trials to find ways to
through the dna
create healthier humans but we're not
going to see
a full suite of dinosaur clones coming
back any time soon as we've seen with
these references to biomedical
technologies they can be utilized for
many advancements generally speaking we
want to be able to shape these changes
towards improving life not only
extension of life but improving quality
of life so we've got to treat these
movies as not only inspirations but
warnings for where things could go and
this is all part of helping us shape a
better tomorrow
thanks so much for watching these clips
with me i hope you learned something
definitely fascinating for me to go
through as well until next time